greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by audit audit calm let me tell you
something as far as supplements are
concerned this is my home from the
protein powder to the alpha brain to the
shroom tech sport and the shroom tech
immune I can't say enough good things
now they just sent me a bag of this
bacon deer elk meat with 21 grams and
pro I mean [ __ ] delicious everything
they do over there plus they got the on
it six now which is a six week [ __ ]
exercise plan that changes your body
right you could do it in your house it's
just a bodyweight exercise I don't know
what it costs but it looks [ __ ]
sensational they just downloaded but you
know what talk is cheap go to alikom
right now take a look at the great list
of supplements they have if there's
something you're interested in press in
charge and get 10% off delivery right to
your house that's how we're doing it
just to get it out of the way number two
one of my favorite companies of all time
I love everything about them from the
rash guards to the ghee and that's Fuji
Sports I'll tell you once a day a
million times if you're looking for a
[ __ ] gay Fuji is the way to go if
you're looking for a nice they've been
in business for they think they know
every nook and cranny of martial arts
from the [ __ ] from the shin guards to
the mouthpieces to the [ __ ]
kettlebell covers I mean they got
everything over there go to Fuji Sports
calm right now impress in church
boom get 10% off all right help to
podcast I'll help yourself out water
quality listen I don't get behind unless
it's [ __ ] quality unless it works I'm
one of those guys I don't care about the
money I'm doing this because it's a
[ __ ] great product so Fuji Sports
calm and on it that's the way to go and
that's the way it's gonna be kick this
[ __ ] melee to Monday the 11th to
[ __ ] June
we're opening up the week with a little
Led Zepplin why not why the front none
it's Monday gravity
it's life
you
what's happened you beautiful
[ __ ] there's a solo podcast
uncle Joey
Lisa ACK coming at you direct and we
want to talk about a few things
the starters welcome to the [ __ ] show
hope you had a great weekend it's Monday
June 11th which means you're getting
dirtier and nastier by the week now with
six months away from [ __ ] Christmas
and you still haven't done anything as
you said you were gonna do January 1st
do you think about that it's already
[ __ ] June 11th and we're still
playing games with ourselves including
myself you know I'm trying to write this
[ __ ] book now today I tried to write
a chapter I'm the worst [ __ ] writer
in all of the world like I am convinced
I am just that [ __ ] bad but you know
what I'll keep plugging along cuz that's
not that the whole [ __ ] momentum
that's the whole patois this show is to
keep showing up who gives a [ __ ] how bad
you want but I was looking at my writing
today every time I write and then I go
to look at the next one I'm we're all
gonna be impressed oh my god is it
[ __ ] bad oh my [ __ ] god
but at least I'm honest I just looked at
the first 10 minutes of the [ __ ]
Netflix special from the 7 o'clock show
oh my god oh my god people but what are
you gonna do I prepared myself I tried
to do everything I could I got on stage
as much as I could
sometimes the pieces just don't come
together but you got the you keep
plugging along man that's why this shows
would be really weird a lot of people
and I don't like this show today I hate
doing shows when when they're marked by
something you know that's going on in
media today I mean we talk about stuff
but very lightly you know how to talk
about a lot of things because other
people talk about it but they better
Adam but this is something I'm really
good at and I want to talk about this
because it bothers the [ __ ] out of me
you know this week we lost another guy
in a [ __ ] suicide we lost two people
but I know nothing about the [ __ ]
checks paid yeah nothing about I don't
know nothing about you know I know about
Anthony Bourdain and you know I wanted
to take a few days to absorb what we're
selling the media a few days to see the
little things they were saying on TV and
I didn't really get much when I thought
about it and I read a lot of the things
that people were saying
you know and listen last year we were
all devastated I mean even if you don't
know somebody even if you don't know
somebody and somebody commits suicide
like Chris Cornell had [ __ ] me up that
[ __ ] me up for a week and still
there's days I put on you know
Badmotorfinger I'll put on [ __ ] hands
all over or I'll [ __ ] output on
Superunknown and I can't believe that
this guy's got him and you know people
go always listen wrong gotta go
that's the beauty of this life that we
all go we're not gonna be around forever
but for somebody like Chris Cornell I
know that you guys have your own
dilemmas you fight for your life the
economy your kid this that and then you
get a guy like Chris Cornell that's on
top of the world or at least we see that
and he hangs himself and then we see a
guy like Anthony Bourdain who's
travelling every week something that
we'd all love to do 18 years 18 [ __ ]
his books you know he had final cut on
all his TV stuff I mean just
unbelievable position to work yourself
off and one morning you wake up and the
guy kills himself and you sit there and
whether you like him or not whether you
like the guy or not listen he wasn't my
best friend I never met the guy I'm just
talking about as a humans perspective
you have to ask yourself what the [ __ ]
is going on with these people let's
start from scratch a dear friend to the
podcast and a dear friend to me from the
Internet is a guy my name of Lauren
Rosenberg and he lost his son a couple
years back and he's still in a tough
position you know I mean I could see it
in his pulse he disappears from time to
time his son when your child takes your
life it's it's it's gotta be devastating
because you don't know you don't know
what's going on they're a little [ __ ]
that you know and then you get a guy
like Anthony Bourdain that 61 and does
the same exact thing you know suicide
and suicide whether you jump off a
bridge you hang yourself you're still
taking your life without thinking about
the people in your life and how it's
gonna affect them never mind you been
a celebrity or somebody who talks about
food you know the guys like you dislike
the endless [ __ ] siren daeho's
there's like the endless [ __ ] siren
where is he going
California Lee weird I mean I've been
thinking about this when everything else
is going on in the world I've been
thinking about why I got that successful
why guy that's the epitome of what all
of us want which is success
money you know people recognize this
this is what most people want alive and
you kill yourself you gotta ask yourself
what the [ __ ] was going on of his head
to me what all that like because you
said with the purse designer all this
week has shown me is just the like nah
none of that stuff makes you happy it
seemed like at the end of the day it
must not because if it did these people
you would never do it Kaizen I was 25 I
was the prison for kidnapping or
whatever the [ __ ] I want the president
for but it was all the same the reason
why I went to jail for us cuz I wanted
money all those years I want to have the
money like it was this [ __ ] thing that
was gonna change my life and I don't
know what happened after I got divorced
and I gotta to stand up and that whole
thing went away and that's when I
started living when I got that whole
money thing out of the way that money is
the biggest lie that's all to us and if
we want to believe that a little bit of
money's gonna make us happy they
approved it this week proved it I mean
one guy well the woman had an excuse her
husband came home and said he wanted to
leave her or whatever you know we don't
know what drove Anthony Bourdain yet but
think about it you know even if you have
money somebody comes to you and says I
want to leave you they leave you still
have your money you still [ __ ] have
your job you still have your child you
know he's Pete's she's had a 16 year old
child you have to think about how this
affects them you know if you don't think
I mean we all know this we all know that
Ronda Rousey's dad took him
took his life you know she she put it
out there on Broad Street and it's on a
couple of the countdowns and whatnot you
don't think that affects around the
Rousey
I mean death and and if your dad dies of
a [ __ ] heart attack while getting the
bread it affects you could you imagine
if your dad killed himself like in your
mind and your little mind you have to
wrap your little head around your dad
gone into a garage at one point of his
life when you were a baby or something
and then having to [ __ ] put a hose in
the car whatever the [ __ ] he that how
unhappy was I what trick was his mind
playing on well I actually spoke with my
therapist about it because it was just I
wasn't like you it wasn't Anthony's
biggest fan but I was a fan I've grown
up with him I've seen his shows and the
happiness thing I and what she said is
that a lot of times the people that
she's spoken to feel like the people are
gonna be better off without them even
though we can probably say that they
wouldn't be that's what like that's what
depression will do to your brain
convinces them like oh it'll be easier
for them if I was not here it'll be
better for them even though yeah he had
a daughter she had kids you know at
first people were looking at as him
Cornell a couple others we're looking at
is like this affects people who are on
drugs at some time in their life alright
so a guy like me and other people listen
to this podcast and we don't family we
were all on drugs at one point you know
this has to scape like where's your mind
gonna go well I mean I and I felt guilty
but that was my first that was my
initial thought when I saw that he had
killed himself because I thought because
I I read either one of in one of his
books or seen on one of the shows that
he was on heroin when he was younger and
I thought I thought it was another like
Philip Seymour Hoffman thing and then he
just started doing heroin again and by
accident he killed himself but and ended
up being for like that the
I must kind of suck that that's gonna be
people's first thought for a LIF you
like pretty open about your drug use
that's gonna be where people go some
people go like oh I wonder if you just
did that again you know I was thinking
as a fact that is like because for some
people after they get sober they can't
find peace they don't feel comfortable
in their own skin I've spoken to people
for years about this because I was very
scared of getting sober myself that
statement I made t on the phone via
there is a true statement I lived with
for years what are you scared of that
your wife is gonna change that's it with
Skinner our wife is gonna change so when
I was on drugs all those years and I
would think about getting off cocaine
they were gone it's not gonna happen
because number one I won't be funny no
more I won't be spontaneous I won't be
alive on stage boy was that a lie boy
was that a lie you know as a matter of
fact I've become a way of better of a
comic since I gave up cocaine there's
only one thing that was good about doing
the cocaine and having that state that
you just went off from time to time but
I still go off right I still go off and
it's not controlled I can't control it
you know it's the same thing as if I was
on cocaine so but I have no regrets but
in your cocaine mind you can't see
yourself without the cocaine even the
reefer like before I got locked up but I
know we spoke about this a few weeks ago
I couldn't think about going getting
locked up without the reefer after I did
a week I was like this ain't [ __ ] right
you know we don't know how strong we
really are we never know how strong we
really are and that's why I wanted to
talk about this time because I'm sure
that there's people I'm listening for
the show they've said to themselves at
one time or another Joey did you ever
think about in my world it was more from
the age of 16 like 18 19 I wanted to
kill myself but I didn't want to be
conscious of doing it I wanted the drugs
to do it or
something to do it you know as a matter
of fact when I did my Lodi in 2005-2006
and boma that was the tail under that I
think nobody hints those pills I knew I
was well aware of what was gonna happen
to me if I kept eating those pills
drinking yank of my sister and I kept
doing it so I could look you in the eye
and talk to the people listen to this
podcast and tell you that yeah
maybe a part of me still had that you
know after a long a shard I went through
some [ __ ] because I thought the Longest
Yard was gonna make peace with me all
these things I thought that we're gonna
make peace with me and they didn't they
didn't make peace with me they didn't do
anything for me it just so happens that
you have to do it for yourself no movie
no movie star no album no music
nothing's gonna give that thing to you
that we're looking for except what we
could heal and once I found that out my
life changed completely so yeah there
was time as I was low on my life I think
there was one or two times 16 and 17
where I physically thought I know one
time at the rummies I thought of jumping
off the George Washington Bridge and
right after my mother died I thought of
stabbing myself but I didn't have the
balls to like I just it's weird how you
worry how cuz I'm just gonna say
sometimes like I've never thought about
I thought just about the idea of it like
you know I haven't I haven't gotten to
the point about let's do this now or
like this but it's weird like sometimes
I'll get down on myself because I think
like oh you could never shoot yourself
in the head and that like that's not
something you should want to be able to
do but it's like oh you'll get down cuz
I get like yeah you won't be able to do
it which is a weird thing to get down on
yourself about but your brain is just
crazy it's just it's we it's it's scary
what it can do to you especially with
going back to war Dean you
you take out the professional stuff it
seemed like he was personally happy
recently it was hidden a girlfriend he
was in when he was in France so that's
every way you look at it you wouldn't
expect it
yeah messes with me parts of me a scared
scared because I wouldn't want my mind
to do that I would never want to let be
listen you never die you take one look
at me I'm halfway dead already anyway
but the point being that I don't want to
go out like that that that beer that
would be a way to hurt that or for me to
do coke right now and to die
what destroy my friends and my family
they were destroyed it would destroy my
daughter it would destroy my wife you
know I can never do something like that
like I said you're gonna die nothing new
yet God gives you so many heartbeats and
once you hit those heartbeats it's over
you know there's not much you could do
there's no negotiation
there's nobody the Saint Lazarus can't
come and save you alright but I would
hate to go out those ways like I would
hate to get back on drugs and go out
that way I wouldn't want to let down you
and my wife and Rogin no one won't let
these people down so right that's one
thing you know oh absolutely and then I
think that's the scariest and also like
the saddest part about it and the thing
that like came to me was you there doing
that in theory or hopefully because
something is so terrible that they can't
deal with it but it's not like that it's
not a relief it's just over it's not the
talk they finally get to relax or like
be okay with it so it's not it's not
really a fix at all unfortunately you
know I always thought about what happens
when you radiate and everything is
starting to fail you and people aren't
paying attention to you like they used
anymore
they have their own lives you know do
you have the right to ice yourself you
know like I've even thought of that
theory like you after your ad sometime
just did in Australia hate to fly to
Amsterdam because he was like over a
hundred or something he was he wasn't
feeling well he was it was like a
scientist but yeah that's a big thing
going on right now there's only a couple
states in America that allow you to do
it like I think Oregon is one of them
but it's not uh I haven't I haven't seen
many of them for like just aids it's
usually for people who were sick well
yeah I mean that's I wonder if like you
there would be like legal battle like
kids wouldn't want their parents to do
it you know when I was 16 17 I really
had nobody and my mind was really
playing tricks on me that like my mind
was really putting guilt trips on me
that like guilt trips about my mother
yelling for me and me not coming
downstairs just tons of guilt trips and
I was there was a period where my mind
went dark for a while he won't I think
about that period that when I want to
write about it it seems like it was
black and white in a black and white
time in my life you know but uh you know
I never really had the balls I got
really [ __ ] up one night when I was
defenders I went over to her party at
Joe Lucci's house and I really got
[ __ ] up I hate to quaaludes dead
people told you just eat one and I hate
two of them when I passed out by 4:00 in
the morning I woke up and went home and
the word was out already so that was I
had turned green
so John bender pulled me aside the next
day and said bro it's all over that you
were [ __ ] dead for a minute or
something like I was really [ __ ] up
like and I part of it was me you know
the pain inside was just
without a mother and what happens going
through no but I'd never one into that
coma and that lived and it was horrible
it was horrible and I kept going you
know and this is why all these things
shot me like the Chris Cornell the
singer from the other band you know the
Anthony Bourdain they shot me because I
was 16 17 there was a young man and once
I knocked on that door I was like oh I'm
lucky that door didn't open you know I'm
very lucky that door didn't open but now
at this age I know I would never even
try to [ __ ] ice myself like no way
might that be [ __ ] no way I don't see
it I hope not I don't see it at no level
but this scares me if this is what I
have to look out for in my mind that
means I have to talk to people I can I
have to talk to people a lot wait this
is the way to do it like I always
thought like suicide hotline and cocaine
and online and all those things were
kind of creepy but now I'm starting to
see that they're not you have to talk to
people you know that you have to talk to
people and you're feeling like this and
I always talked to my wife I let my wife
know I read it a couple of weeks ago I
wasn't feeling to do it that pulled her
aside and told her not tell people like
that one that I felt really shitty
before I left the province that week
that Monday I felt really shitty
I told Donovan at the fourth wall I was
like I'm really scared of leaving
because I don't feel good I don't feel
up to par like my body's not feeling
well I'm not feeling well I would hate
for my wife to have to fly the Tennessee
drop off the baby and then fly to New
York to see me in the hospital like I
was even concerned about that I mean if
we do go to the worst possible scenarios
that's and that's another scary thing
the thing that I've always been a
hypochondriac oh yeah yeah I'm very very
much a hypochondriac
you made a pretty funny statement here
that he said that I thought about what
you said you said that you had read
something about how much LeBron James
spent on himself you know and it's so
funny I thought about your statement you
gotta remember Lee there was a time I
was spending the minimum minimum are 400
weeks out of drugs that's 1,600 well I'm
so much were you making a month of that
point I have no idea I sit here
sometimes and I hey you know you have
the 400 times four equals sixteen
hundred um all right
times twelve twelve equals nineteen to a
year that's mental
you gotta remember I was getting let's
just go for a grammar blow let's just go
for a grammar blow times 7 it's 4:20 a
week and I was getting the grammar we
that they're 20 bucks that's another 140
plus 145 60 that's twenty-two twenty
three hundred just on drugs alone so if
I go to jujitsu right plus I go to
kickboxing plus I go to cry cry all
right
plus I gonna whatever acupuncture
acupuncture to or lowes a month I'm
still ahead by 1500 can you imagine that
you know [ __ ] imagine that so what I
was spending on that was evil from my
mind in my body now I spend the quarter
on and I and good stuff and it's good
stuff a quarter of what I was spending
between the kickboxing to cry or a month
the [ __ ] a coupon
- its it's just amazing what happens
what the result is what you get back
from where you put it how healthy my
mind is how healthy I feel our healthy
my eyes are just a lot of things that I
wouldn't have been right now so I was
spending that close to two grand a month
now I'm spending a little under five
hundred a month and I'm getting a bigger
result how the [ __ ] could that be think
about that for a second you know what
that's like 400 a week that's just let's
pretend I got high five days a week
that's five times 60 that's what that's
300 right and let's say I bought a gram
of coke top gram of weed six days that's
120
I had a 140 so one forty and three is
four forty that's still eighteen hundred
a month do you have no idea
plus the road when I was spending on
coke on the road cuz I would go on the
road and spend my whole check I would
come back with a hundred bucks and no
part of you thought what do you think
about saving during the day be like I'm
gonna start saving there was nobody in a
car there was no saving in my world god
it's weird how like different things
affect different people forty years
there was no saving and you weren't
nervous about it at all I didn't open up
a bank account I was 43 holy [ __ ] before
I got off coke at 45 I think right some
fire yeah yeah 44 I opened up a bank
account at 43 I was putting like five
hours a month in that I like 35 hours
when I [ __ ] quit the coke Lynette $33
so what would you just have all the cash
you've had on you yeah at all times yeah
Jesus you may put a Sulha
100 or three in the jacket and just
leave it there for an hour because I
would say I'm gonna save this and that
burn right to [ __ ] through it and if
there's a way like how it's it's crazy
my mind set was crazy the way I thought
was crazy I was headed to do him I was
headed to fail it everything about this
plan I had was about making money
snorting first and everything else was
second but I didn't have my not high
enough for it to affect or anything I
kept my nut small so it didn't affect
anything so nobody could tell what I was
doing if I was driving them to Sadie's
and then you'd see me in the Subaru you
go something's going on but I always
kept everything small that's wild
then you basically do you did a budget
but you got your everything else your
apartment car to as low as humanly
possible so you could snort as much code
as much coke no wonder where you know
just just bad bones of life but you had
why don't you wear underwear now that's
the thing I still wear on the way you
want to look you weren't trying to Jitsu
ya world I knew it all right
I like on the wearing jeans field really
all wear jeans I like on the wind sweats
for you but I like on the wearing jeans
feel like you're weeping like oh we had
Sunday we got a smoke
you always wear jeans I tried it I like
jeans but it's just it makes you think
that's it it's just really food for
thought when people take their lives and
like I said I don't know much about
depression I don't understand much about
that mindset I respect it I understand
that to a degree but on the stand is
fully I
situations where I want to jump off a
[ __ ] bridge more than ten times like
most people in their lifetime I have one
hand you know the death of their mom to
death of their dad maybe they wanted to
do something with their life maybe a
heartbreak you know for me I had heart
bracelets how I was younger and yeah
most of it was inflicted by me I'm no
[ __ ] the special case here but you
figure after the tenth time you know you
just say [ __ ] this [ __ ] you know once
you get into this racket that woman
this is suicidal move he'll this ain't
no [ __ ] normal living this is
suicidal living to really be good at
this there's one point in your life
where you have to just remove everything
and it could end in suicide hope not I
mean it's cuz it sounds like you're
you're not afraid of opening up to
people like that's my issue was like
that I like the therapist cuz I I'm
getting better at talking I would never
tell anybody before if I was feeling a
certain way I just didn't really feel
comfortable doing it sounds like you're
a little bit more comfortable so maybe
that's maybe you don't need it but
that's that that's why I like therapy
just even just to get those thoughts out
of my head and I've said it before but
do you eat but even if it's not that
level of depression sometimes if
something's bothering me and I just say
it I'll realize while telling my
therapist like oh this isn't as big of a
deal as I've been making it I live in
Hollywood tell that to her but like II I
haven't had really had like thought
about suicide since I've had persons
I've been with her but I don't know if
I'd feel comfortable telling somebody so
I think that's why it's it's good that
you do tell people I guess maybe that's
why you don't get let it get as far well
me I never let's just get this out in
the open I may talk some [ __ ] and I may
say some crazy [ __ ] from time to time I
do not understand the psyche tired
thing because I believe in the gift of
friendship I really do believe in the
gift of friendship I don't think people
use it enough I may have six friends in
the world but I know everything about
you the six friends I have I know them
inside and out
I know them better than they know
themselves that's what you do is having
a good friend 40 50 years 30 years you
know I'm looking for quality you know
you're not looking for quantity quantity
you're looking for quality I'd rather
have two good [ __ ] friends than five
mediocre [ __ ] jerk-offs so because I
have you George lubes James Timmy I got
people I know who they are so when
they're acting a little off I whack them
and let them know yo - saying what you
doing you're falling outside that
perimeter yet and because I have friends
like that I use them the same way I
can't see like I can't see paying
somebody to talk to them when you have
good friends that you could talk to and
nobody knows you like your friends like
if right now what I need to think about
really well I did I didn't know a lot of
ways you know you have to trust your
friends so you go to a for your friends
to read your friends and your list I'm
doing a special helped me out when you
start with people just cell about the
relationship you have when you start
with certain comics when you're both
gonna wind up for a year or two together
and then you break away they know
everything about you the same way you
know about that
while you're talking to that waitress
you're listening to their set and you're
going he's doing that joke again oh he's
doing that differently not you know
you're learning about that person so me
I've always had a hard time with
psychiatry not because I like psychology
because I believe in my friends if you
have good friends they should ground you
and you could get grounded just by
talking to them on a daily you don't
even have to ask them you don't even
really have to ask you know what they're
gonna live with and what they're not
gonna live one and the reason why you
don't want them to know about certain
things is because you don't want them to
know about that that you live in through
that behavior again because don't pick
it right the [ __ ] up kut'rs mention the
to him look bro you're doing that thing
again aren't you no no no I'm just going
over there once a week we're not [ __ ]
with you you know so I take pride in
that but I have friends that I know I'm
inside of that and they know me inside
that yeah III I mean I think I'm not
lucky enough to have at least that level
of friendship with that many people and
then also even the ones that I do I have
another now this is heroin con 2 that ok
there's a pro and con that the pro the
con is that your friends aren't really
gonna tell you the truth but that's a
lie I'd rather hear the truth from my
friend than the truth from a stranger
why that
what do you think they will tell you the
truth yeah yeah I came from somewhere
where they tell you the truth that's why
I'm the way I am
all those years when I was slipping my
friends would mention things to me from
time to time and it would hurt my
feelings a little bit in fact it would
piss me off for a few weeks but then I
knew were that when they came with that
from what place they showed up with that
and it made my life a lot easier and
whether I changed about I looked at them
a little differently like they really
cared yeah at least they care but do I
want to take you how long does it take
you to open up to people that's my
biggest issue like it's hard for me to
make friends cuz it did even there's the
little opening up is tough but to tell
to tell someone how I'm feeling like
that's even that's even tougher listen
I've known Joe Rogan for 20 years and
there's a lot of things I can't tell him
but I tell my friends I grew up with
sorry buddy is different everybody's
different you know was gonna understand
you and you know who's not gonna
understand you and if you don't know
you're gonna find out the hard way right
you know what people can understand you
know where people can't understand you
well I could tell Ari
I can't tell Joe and Tom's are going
there to close-knit they're to their
morals or to you know I'm saying I could
tell Ari basically there's people you
could just tell mommy come up recycle is
what went down the other there's certain
people that you have certain friends
that tell your friends don't get me
wrong be your best friend but they
wouldn't go over with that too good so
in a way they're really not your best
friends you know I'm saying in a way
they're good friends but they're not all
the way that the kids I grew up with and
Jersey that I talked on the phone still
they ground me they don't let me believe
this [ __ ] that's going on they don't let
me believe anything I'm still Coco
that's why I get mad at them when they
call me Joe
oh really yeah I'm like
friends call window they're gonna call
me Coco cuz I still wanna feel like that
person I never want to not feel like
that person even if it's just flat
through conversation I still want to
remember that that person is still
closed by that Coco was still close by
you know it bothered me about the
Anthony Bourdain thing and Crisco now
because people were comparing it to
people had done drugs one thing about me
is that's why I always smoke pop and his
lame isn't excuses this sounds like I
was in two halfway houses I was at three
halfway houses okay I've been around
people that are trying to get clean for
30 [ __ ] years
I know people still today they're trying
to get clean that I was getting high
with okay I'd personally know three
people right now like I could call up on
the phone but I was getting high with we
were getting coke from the same place
they're still getting hot [ __ ] I'm not
saying that I know how to get somebody
cleaned but I know the ways to keep you
there okay because it's all a mental
thing staying clean the biggest thing is
losing something you feel like you
losing something that's why I continued
to smoke pot because I didn't want to
feel like I lost something and I can
look you in the face right now I'm tight
it when I bring when I wake up in the
morning this is when this weed gets me
in I this is when I really need this
week throughout the day I'm just loving
to waste my time that's why I got to eat
22 of those mints that's why I got to
eat 300 400 milligrams of THC because my
resistance is so uh I smoked it because
it's like a blanket for me it is a
psychiatrist in a way so even though
things have gotten so bad on the coke he
still felt like you were like missing
something yes you're losing yes anybody
who's been on drugs and he drew
at all and then get off it a piece of
their life is good they won't tell you
this but it's the truth they know it
they know that life is never gonna be
the same again they really enjoy getting
on you think I did drugs I did enjoy
yeah I loved it I love me the girl like
cake quickly and get an Eightball lock
him up in a hotel room doing disgusting
perverted things and taking pictures
coming all over the place and I feeling
like the [ __ ] lose the next day
because that's what you feel like a
complete loser when the cocaine is done
whatever drugs you're doing a gun and
you come down and you have that come
down face over your your habit that's a
horrible feeling
that's a suicidal feeling also yeah
what's the drugs are gonna London you're
like wow and also your life comes up in
front of you and even though now you did
the drugs see because you have this pain
and you did the drugs and it shut down
the pain for the nine hours over the
eight hours that you were doing the
drugs for but even now that you're numb
the pain starts to recede at 5:00 or
6:00 in the morning and that's when it
really sucks when you're sitting there
after nine hours of doing drugs and the
pain is still coming through but you can
block it you're like wow that's amazing
that the plane that still comes through
good it's good to know
you know it's kind of a weird weird
weird feeling something that never made
sense to me is they have her it's a big
thing in movies or TV and I think in
real life that people drink to forget
stuff that have I've just met just
luckily maybe never use do that as lame
as it always sounds for me the only
thing that I can connect to the way
you're saying is the way I am with food
which I know isn't as as dangerous but
to me like to the thought of trying to
block pain with alcohol doesn't even
like it doesn't even make sense to me
but I don't people must do it they get
so drunk they can't remember or I don't
know I don't even know how it works it's
just to forget you know anything to
forget whether it's the weed the pills
it's anything to forget a little to take
you away from that moment in time and
it's uh you know living with that pain
is very weird whether it's you know a
divorce or a child or a death or a death
of a parent or a death of a friend or a
[ __ ] spouse pain is real man you know
and there's different ways to deal with
it and that's what it is we all have to
find a way to deal with that pain out of
control it and then we went you know the
pain is always gonna be there the pain
is always gonna be there for whatever
reason is you just learn how to work
with it you know
where's telling you better that
[ __ ] let's give a shout out to my
man Dante Kazemi
Lorne Rosen Kirk Bobby Sherrod
Bobby Lee Linda's my man one by one
podcast were laying Carson Brandi Lynn
over there
don't forget her GoFundMe page my man
Leon watching the fights last night cash
is Morris and the Man of Steel Scott
Cunningham putting the [ __ ] church
paid together with you [ __ ] and
a shout out to the [ __ ] Minister of
Defense Dickie syat down man and West
Palm Beach show Florida was showing up
with a big dick of the [ __ ] bellyache
and I'm saying ever since you gave that
poison ain't given any poison haven't
[ __ ] taco places [ __ ] he's had poison
but no it's just really weird that I
wanted to bring this to the park to the
church family because I had been
thinking about it affected me it takes a
lot to [ __ ] bring me down and I
wanted to talk to you guys to see how
you felt about it I know there's a lot
of people go through things that go on
that page and people who email me and
people with Facebook me listen man just
do me a favor you know I would love to
tap Kate one of your friends one of you
good friend sit him down take him to
lunch even if you don't want to other
words suicide don't say that word but
that you might be calling them one night
that there's times that you get thoughts
just let somebody know let somebody know
who you love somebody who loves you
somebody who cares for you man we all
have one [ __ ] person you don't have
to sit them down and go me I get
suicidal thoughts and only goes blabs
his [ __ ] mouth and next thing you
know what people calling it nothing
that's why I'm saying don't use that
word just tell them that tell when your
friends that you're wrestling with
something you know about your career
that you might be calling them one night
you know like your friends know prepare
that let them know that you're going
through something you don't have to say
suicide you don't have to say you want
to take a swan dive you don't have to
say you want to shoot yourself you don't
do use any of those words just tell them
that you're going through anxiety even
if it's those words those are the words
I use because I really don't know what
it is that I'm going through this times
I go through something before I go on
stage you know but there's times I'm in
my office and I get so [ __ ]
frustrating the guys that I cut out a
blackout in a way wait I just kind of
like I'm gonna pass out or something
like that I'm telling you guys because I
need you guys I need you guys to
understand how this works I get so
frustrated some nights where I can't
[ __ ] see straight and you know it's
like that night that I didn't go to the
Mitzi shore thing but I had the anxiety
attack here and at home and I wouldn't
[ __ ] take the medication I wouldn't
take that I breathe through it I dealt
with it you know it's not always about a
pill it's about a workout it's about
getting a notebook you know it's about
writing [ __ ] down you know I complained
to you guys a lot the last two weeks
about my sleep when I didn't complain
about is whether whatever I can't sleep
there's a trigger there's a trigger
you're not that [ __ ] stupid I'm no
psychiatrist I didn't take four years I
have
but I'm not that dumb you get a notebook
and you write it up you feel something
you got a notebook you write it out and
then you read it I can't tie an
important reading it is
never mind writing and writing it and
then reading it and reading what you're
going through really some of the flies
in your mind really breaks it down to
your mind it's not just writing it it's
reading what you're going through like I
tell you when I [ __ ] around with you
guys and tell you oh my god
yeah I robbed this [ __ ] drug-dealing
we all get a little giggle that's one
thing when I go home and write that
story out and I read it oh do I feel
[ __ ] terrible about myself
horrible horrible but while we're here
giggle about it we have a good giggle
you know and I feel shitty on the drive
home and I go home and write about it
and then I read it and it's not a
[ __ ] giggle and you could do the same
with your mind your mind is just
thoughts random thoughts you ever can't
sleep at night what are you thinking
about just random thoughts that you have
no [ __ ] you have no reason to be
thinking about them after that half the
time half this [ __ ] that goes in our
mind you should not be thinking about
yeah it's got nothing to do with your
day today I was sitting there playing
tennis with mercy you know we just hit a
little circle ball and my phone went off
and there was an email from my agent who
my brain has a feature to Cleveland
October if I had was there I was
strangled with my hand cuz not only is
it four months away but it's [ __ ]
Sunday and you want to know who I'm
bringing to Cleveland there's a [ __ ]
feature act that's what you're trying to
tell me on a Sunday these are things you
don't need to worry about like if you
bother me with that out like a 22 I
didn't know I thought that was important
that's not important you see how mad I
get here when you hit me about hold on
the podcast Friday we didn't even do
Monday's podcast why are you worried
about Friday 4:00 so I've learned how to
eliminate all those things over the
years but boy I'm still [ __ ] horrible
I mean so I can't imagine where you go
through and with other people and they
hit me with emails on the podcast about
sometimes a hard time I can't imagine it
because I'm the king of it I was the
king of eliminating that [ __ ] out of my
mind sometimes it goes back to middle
school oh there's something like some
guy and some kid said to me in seventh
grade then I'll never forget and like I
said I've said it on stage but I haven't
found a way to make it funny yet but
it's it's it's stuff like that not even
doesn't matter it's not even like a week
old it's 15 20 years ago that for some
reason I remember and then just you get
stuck in your brain so that's I think
it's similar to saying it to a therapist
but that's probably why writing and
reading helps you is it just out it's
just out and you can see it yeah I don't
wanna I need to I need to read it write
it read it and then uh what's the word
I'm looking for processing you really
need like oh listen man I struggle with
a lot of the things I did 20 years ago
it may not appear to you like I do but I
really do some of those crime stories
are a little bit much and if you're a
regular human being with morals you're
like what am i doing talking to this
Laura what am i doing listening to his
[ __ ] jokes his [ __ ] dumb podcast I
mean cuz there are a little bit much and
if you don't think I real struggle with
those a lot of those stories you're out
of your mind you know the other day I
was thinking about Saraiva you know I
was thinking about how I pulled that
stunt on my [ __ ] Godfather where I
didn't pay him the money you know and he
died God knows he was thinking when he
died but his thoughts were unpleasant
about me you know I mean there was a lot
of people I went down all but he is
trust me I'm telling you you know it's
it's not way no it's I don't feel good
sometimes yeah it's a different game but
I still did what I did and I didn't
forget it and that's
really [ __ ] important though I never
forgot about the things I did you know
when I ran him down and I wrestle with
him and hey it was a long time ago you
know you can't cry over spilt milk but
you also did him and you have to deal
with the consequences and I do I do deal
with them and I feel bad you know for
every ten kids that hit me from North
America in Union City in Hudson County
that's saying they're a fan every once
in a while it's a kid hit me out on
Facebook saying my dad said you robbed
him you're a piece of [ __ ] you know he
was your friend than you robbed you know
[ __ ] like that
I get those once a month and the people
who say they love me those are great
emails you know that made me feel great
put those little simple ones that's I
robbed the dad or I was involved in
something they bothered me too they
bother me a lot too
and I'll do just that I'll take a
notebook out rip it out go to a coffee
shop and write the story out and then
read it make some notes on how bad I
feel or [ __ ] him for what he did maybe I
remember something he did then
antagonize the whole [ __ ] deal and it
makes me not feel as bad as I should do
I deal with all this [ __ ] so for you
people who hear me giggling with Lee and
Joe Rogan and telling the story
that's my way of dealing with it you
know it's like yesterday during the
sports boot thing I talked about Anthony
Bourdain I cranked the junk even the guy
from a sports booth told me today that
they were laughing but on the web page
when it comes to death that's how I deal
with it is by crack I dealt with so much
death earlier that the only way I could
deal with it is by cracking a joke at a
funeral I come to your dad's funeral god
forbid to crack out a joke to you and
you're gonna look at me and go Jesus
Christ Joey when does it end what you
gonna laugh and you know that was a
[ __ ] good one because I'm not gonna
hit you with a bad joke and a [ __ ]
wake I'm gonna throw he that [ __ ] and
make you go Jesus Christ that was a
[ __ ] sensation
and do you think about it beforehand
like do you prepare a joke because it's
funny that the meds how you deal with it
is humour now sometimes you gotta waking
your dad's got a tuxedo on you no
[ __ ] them award tuxedo and he
came to a comedy show tonight I want
somewhere to see the one there's a way
to have you know there's so many [ __ ]
things that happen on the wake of the
funeral just funny number two for you
know me you know I'm gonna hate you
about what you get no well I'm always
gonna hit you at that where were we in
the will who do we have to hit the head
with a brooms you got a bigger [ __ ]
envelope we have to bury your sister
right behind the [ __ ] is some fulfilled
Paula so we have to crash a car Princess
Diana style you know what do we need to
do to get your sister out of the picture
so we got a bigger envelope we get the
patio furniture you never saying we need
that patio furniture we need to make a
poker game here as though oh my god no
but you always add light to a a death by
cracking a [ __ ] joke it's a work for
you yeah must don't when I found my
mother on the floor I cracked a joke in
my [ __ ] head that's pretty crazy
I'm the way of trying to pick her up and
revive her looking at her black and blue
on from the heart attack I cracked a
joke because I needed that moment of
levity if that I would have ran out of
the [ __ ] house crying so I always
crack a joke to myself or something just
to level out the [ __ ] situation just
to not make it as bad as this so please
Lou [ __ ] work with me on these little
[ __ ] details here and that's it and
that's that this is just a quick little
[ __ ] podcast to let you know how I
feel about it
to see how you people felt about it to
see how you people deal with these
things and if suicide is [ __ ]
bothering you like I said but you have
two ways to deal with it you got friends
you got friends plant the seed in their
head let them know that you're going
through something if you're embarrassed
to talk about it and you have a hotline
but don't leave people hanging don't
leave us hangin thinking what do we do
or what could we have done to help you
that's a helpless [ __ ] feel it
that's a helpless [ __ ] feeling don't
do that to people that care for you you
know when I wanted to get off coke it
was two reasons I wanted to prove people
wrong in the two I didn't want my wife
Terry to find me she didn't this Lea
doesn't deserve to find me on the floor
not some people yeah you're a piece of
[ __ ] of the way you've done [ __ ] up
[ __ ] there you go a little something for
the podcast people can't start off a
Monday without a good fart you never
saying but this habit one Terry to find
me on the floor with a purple [ __ ]
arm and my nose all [ __ ] black and
blue from [ __ ] snorting coke and the
my I don't want that I did not want that
you can handle it and you have to think
like that sometimes you really do you
have to think about the people I love
you and the people that care for you so
before you do that dumb [ __ ] like when I
was doing all that dumb [ __ ] it's
because I would put in my mind purposely
that nobody gave a [ __ ] about me well
that's what I was gonna say that I think
that there's a lot of people that feel
like that yes they don't have friends I
would put that in my mind all the time
nobody gives a [ __ ] about me so Lea come
rob this thing I will take the gun you
sit in the car and you go why I want to
go I really want to shoot that guy go no
no because if we get caught you got a
mom of the dad I got nothing so I would
put in my head that nobody cares for me
that was my excuse to do the crazy
things I did you know which I wouldn't
[ __ ] knows you know how you do them and
you move on and you live in I don't live
there no more I do not live there some
of the things I did bring me down but I
don't let them get me down they bring me
down for a minute or two but I don't
stay there I get myself out of it I
remind myself of what I was the person
who I was and who I am today and what I
am today and I don't stay there because
that's not who I am anymore at all how
long did it take you to be able to do
that though years took me years to deal
with all these things that's I mean it's
you have to really be honest with
yourself and that's something that I
think a lot of people can't do is be
honest either with their friend
even just for themselves is hard it's
hard to be brutally honest um since 1990
I went on a mission to do something good
every day because for years I had done
something bad every day and even if
there was there was days I just
shoplifted you know in 95 and 94 of 1990
mmm I really make a conscious note to
try to do good but if I had a dollar I
would give away 80 cents or somebody
just for the bad things I had done
before like I put that in my head that's
really in my head even today and today
that's what makes me feel good about
myself that I can help young comics I
can help some people out you know last
week we do keep spooky I've made it up
to Ralphie you know that wasn't my thing
I love wookie I would have brought Loki
anywhere I hugged away anything for
houki but I wanted to do that for who he
and for Ralphie it didn't mean anything
to me you know I'm saying get her a
plane ticket of flying her up what's the
difference what someone's paid in taxes
anyway you know but it wasn't about the
300 bucks it was about the commitment
and making somebody's day that's what it
was about and for somebody not to make
my day in the future but maybe someday
my daughter's gonna need for somebody to
make it day and that karma gesture will
come back to her and the person won't
try to [ __ ] her I won't try to put a
pillar or soda or nothing like that
that's why you give people the respect
they deserve and you never have problems
you know yeah I was a piece of [ __ ] for
30 years maybe for 35 years I'll tell
you well for the last 2530 Everman you
know the last 20 I've really tried every
day to do something so I would never do
before
something conscious to make somebody's
day whether it's the cat's whether it's
a neighbor or whether it's a ride
something well how much is having a kid
change that because yeah I mean you do
you look at her not wanting to go
through these issues is that what makes
you think about it I look at her oh nice
go through these issues and I look at
her and I don't want her to get hit with
a karma move from me
because you have sins of your father
that you have to live with and I worry
about that there's a lot of creepy
things I'd [ __ ] did and I worry about
that she's gonna be a recipient of like
karma that I did you know specifically
four or five things that I'm scared of
well I pray I try to be a good man every
day I try to help somebody every day I
try to take somebody whose frown away to
a smile that's it I'm not talking about
giving somebody money or no just taking
somebody's frown oi to a smile talking
to them on the phone they making them
laugh something you know checking in
with somebody letting somebody know
they're not alone in the world it's
[ __ ] good it's good for you it's a
little disciplines that you do to help
you you know anybody could donate 500
bucks to something that that's not it
that's not it I want you to work for a
little bit every day I'm waiting on the
phone I may have to mail something I
don't want you to have to something
something to show the universe that
you're a human being you know that's
what I had to do after all those years
surely you own the universe that I was a
human being that's tough because the
universe is senior other sides he saw
the wallets I stole all the dumb [ __ ] I
did you know so but like I said if
anybody's going through stuff or
whatever please before you jump or hang
yourself whatever [ __ ] you're gonna do
that the sad our world talk to somebody
that's the most important thing knowing
people talk to somebody people are there
for you you'd be [ __ ] surprised and
it's the person you least expect but you
have your friends and if you got to pay
somebody 140 hours pay something for
whenever it takes for you not to [ __ ]
jump off the building and that's it and
that's that don't forget next Saturday
my Colusa casino would sold the [ __ ] out
July 13th and 14th at the South Point in
Las Vegas and July 26th and 27th at
wiseguys in Utah don't know when the
Netflix specials coming out but I'll let
you know the date and we'll have a
[ __ ] party and we'll stream and we'll
do the whole [ __ ] thing beside that
don't forget Fuji Sports calm these mats
shin guards boxing gloves whatever the
[ __ ] you need rash guards Fuji Sports
has it Fuji Sports has it tremendous
quality tremendous durability toughening
[ __ ] and its quality you pay a dolly get
a dollars worth of quality and that's
what I [ __ ] tell you people that's why
I like Fuji jeez that's why I like the
rash guards that's why I believe in them
so do me a favor how about the Churchill
what's happening now well the Fuji
sports.com right now press in charge man
and get 10% off your order right now
number two from day one I've worked with
[ __ ] on it today I made the best
Mexican chocolate protein shake you've
ever had in your life that's on it the
best the best [ __ ] Horbury goes
around the world to get you the best
[ __ ] ingredients whether it's talc
bacon sausage whether it's the [ __ ]
shroom tech sport whether it's a shroom
tech immune whether it's the alpha brain
which comes 100% money-back guarantee
and we don't want the product that's
what [ __ ] haunted does going on it
right now I can't help you with the
weights and everything else but as far
as supplements I'll get you 10% off so
go to hala calm right now and press in
church ban and get 10% off your order
delivered to your house don't forget I
love you [ __ ] we'll be back
Wednesday morning ready to rock and I'll
see you then have a great week have a
great Monday don't let nobody [ __ ] with
you and remember we're out there to help
man so before you do that swan dive make
a [ __ ] call have a great day we love
you [ __ ] stay black take this
[ __ ] meal leave
[Music]